directed by James McTighe and produced
by the Wachowskis ninja assassins of
story of rise Oh an orphan who's
recruited into a shadowy kind of ninjas
who carried out political assassinations
Ninja Assassin didn't do much of the box
office when it debuted in 2009 but since
then has become a cult favorite why
here's a look at the untold truth of
Ninja Assassin it started as a joke
during the filming of Speed Racer there
were child Keys brought in stunt
coordinator chadster housekey who had
worked with them on the Matrix trilogy
while working on a fight scene that
involves Korean pop star rain Sahel ski
had an epiphany telling spire magazine
we always kind of had a running joke
with her with Charles Keats about making
a kick-ass ninja movie we told them we
found our ninja and brought rain in to
do a fight sequence and everyone was
like only this guy is good within a few
months that running joke was in
production under the title ninja
assassin rain did his own stunts many
action flicks rely on stuntmen to do the
heavy lifting for big set pieces but
ninja assasin went the other way as rain
did almost all his own stunt work with
very little while work or special
effects how well rain started by
training eight hours a day five days a
week for eight straight months in order
to pull off both fight sequences and
stunts like slipping off of moving
curves now that's dedication inventive
hardware Ninja Assassin features one of
the coolest weapons ever seen in a
martial arts film that's blade and chain
Seng raizo uses to hack through
mountains of ninjas although you can now
buy it on Amazon it actually didn't
exist before ninja assasin the
production team invented it just for
rain sure chain weapons aren't entirely
a new concept but figuring out the
physics of their modified yo katsu show
GAE required a lot of trial and error
before they hit on exactly the right
formula and having an all new type of
weapon meant a creative challenge for
the fight choreographers who works with
Ranger invent a totally unique fighting
style chadster hell ski said as he went
through the training
rain kept getting better so he had to
keep me choreographing what we had
designed originally he outgrew by the
time we were ready to shoot the more
rain the abilities developed the more
our choreography has to evolve
53 our scripts no movie works without a
good story which is why most scripts are
in developed
for months then there's the scrubs
pfenninger assassin which Babylon 5
creator J michael Straczynski wrote in
just 53 hours flat that speed was
required because with just 6 weeks left
until filming what sets up again what
Charles Keyes decided to scrap the
scripts they already had
according to Straczynski after the
rutowski schooled him he went home and
put on a plots of coffee and wrote
essentially a whole new script in 53
hours when a friend calls you and says
they're in trouble
you do what you have to do show kosugi
is a ninja legend ninja assassins brutal
antagonist those ooh do may not be a
familiar face to you but hardcore fans
of ninja films know that he's played by
none other than the legendary show
kosugi who helped kickstart the ninja
craze in the 80s of films like enter the
ninja revenge of the ninja and ninja 3
the domination director james McTeague
decided early that he wanted to cast
Kousuke as the villain in ninja assasin
as a tribute to those old ninja films
and kosugi was happy to come out of
retirement to play the part the decision
certainly worked as a zoo new is one of
the most terrifying movie villains in
recent years the orphans were random
German kids some of the most intense
scenes in the movie are the flashbacks
involving young Rizzo training with the
other orphans under Moscow Zoo new so
how did McTeague populates that mystical
dojo he just found some random kids well
sort of the movie was filmed in Berlin
so McTigue went around to all of the
local martial arts schools and found a
handful of kids who seemed like they
knew what they were doing then trained
them in his own Hollywood way mystique
grabbed up a bunch of children the same
way as Onew did in the film guest life
really does imitate earth the blood was
styled like anime ninja assasin has a
lot of blood but there's a certain art
to making all that gore looks good in
fact McTigue studied classic anime hits
ninja scroll and samurai champloo to
perfect the stylized look of the blood
after all as McTeague Pusser what's a
ninja movie without blood right
amen to that a real heartbreaker in the
opening scene of ninja assasin
an old tattoo artist explains that he
seen the ninja assassins once before and
the only reason he's still alive is
because his heart is on the wrong side
of his chest when the ninja stabbed him
in the heart they missed
may seem like a goofy gimmick but that
half of a wrong size thing is totally
real
it's called situs inversus and it
happens when a person's internal organs
are flipped around to the opposite side
of the body it's pretty rare so yeah the
chances of two people who are targeted
by the same ninja clan having the same
medical condition is a stretch but it's
not impossible even some celebrities
like singer Andrey K Iglesias have situs
inversus so say what you want about
Iglesias but the guy's pretty much a
mutant ninjas thanks for watching click
the Lupo icon to subscribe to my youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know your love thing
[Music]